it's hard to talk about this stuff
without sounding self-righteous that's
my nightmare I'm trying to not sound
self-righteous about all this because
it's my pet peeve when people are
self-righteous in conversations and I
try to remember though that when
someone's self-righteous it usually just
means they care so much about something
that they become an asshole right I do
it I'm guilty I am guilty I am very into
animal advocacy and thank you what else
am I gonna do there are times when I am
so passionate about protecting an
innocent animal that I will be a jerk to
a human it happens kind of a lot yes
recently I saw a stray dog at this huge
intersection in Los Angeles and nobody
was stopping nobody was stopping so I
pull over and I can see that it's a
little tiny puppy and I could tell it
was in really bad shape okay so I get
out of my car and this guy yells him
he's like you dumb bitch and I was like
like screaming at all these people and I
finally get like 12 lanes to stop and I
get closer to this puppy and I get
closer and closer to this little tiny
puppy and I see that this little tiny
puppy is a trash bag
[Applause]
and I had already been such an asshole
that there was really no turning back at
this point so I just had set his head to
lean in
[Applause]
and that's how I got tetanus